لطالم مثل الذهب اهميه كبيره للبشر منذ
القدم فبجانب استخدامه في الحلي والزنا
يعد كذلك ثروه يعتمد عليها الافراد والدول
ويشكل وركيزه اساسيه في النظام النقدي
الدولي وعند الازمات يلجا الجميع الى
المعدن النفيس باعتباره ملاذا امنا وهو ما
المح اليه ضمن تقرير مجلس الذهب العالمي
الذي كشف عن رفع البنوك المركزيه العالميه
احتياطياتها من الذهب باسرع مثيره منذ 55
عاما حين كانت الدولار وقتها مدعوما
بالذهب
وتشير بينته مجلس الذهب العالمي الى ان
البنوك المركزيه اشترت نحو اربع مئه طن من
الذهب بقيمه 20 مليار دولار في الربع
الثالث من العام المنصرم مع عوده الطلب
الى مستويات ما قبل الجائحه
وجاء على راس البنوك المركزي التركي كاكبر
مشتري للذهب بعد ان يستحوذ على 31 طنا في
الربع الثالث يليه البنك المركزي الازبكي
بس 26 طن ثم بنك الاحتياطي الهندي بسبعه
عشر طنا يليه مصرف قطر المركزي بشراء 15
طنا في الربع الثالث
اللافت ان تقديرات مجلس الذهب العالمي
تفوق المشتريات المبلغ عنها الى صندوق
النقد الدولي والبنوك المركزيه ويرى خبراء
في اسواق المعادن النفيسه ان اللجوء
البنوك المركزيه الى الذهبيه يعود الى
الاوضاع الجنسيه التي تعكس حاله من عدم
اليقين وعدم الثقه بعد ان جمدت الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها احتياطيه الدولار في
روسيا وفسرت صحيفه فاعلن سلطان البريطانيه
التناقض بين تقديرات مجلس الذهب العالمي
والارقام الرسميه بانه يعود الى شراء
الوكالات الحكوم والبنوك المركزيه في
روسيا والصين وغيرها من الدول الذهب من
دون الابلاغ عن دخوله بالاحتياطيات كما
لفتت الى ان اخر مره شهد فيها هذا المستوى
من شراء الذهب كانت عام
1967 حين اشترت البنوك المركزيه الاوروبيه
كميات هائله من الذهب من الولايات المتحده
ما ادى الى ارتفاع الاسعار وانهيار نظام
بريتنودز الذي ربط قيمه الدولار الامريكي
بالذهب